Прокладання газопроводу "Північний потік-2", який
має напряму постачати газ з Росії у Німеччину через
Балтійське море, не має економічно виправданого підґрунтя.
Про це Петро Порошенко заявив напередодні
свого візиту до Берліна.
Кращою альтернативою президент України вважає
модернізацію української газотранспортної системи,
що, на його думку, значно дешевше.
Будівництво "Північного потоку-2" коштуватиме
європейським компаніям близько 9 мільярдів євро
за газопровід протяжністю 1200 кілометрів дном
Балтійського моря та потужністю 55 мільярдів
кубометрів газу на рік.
Транзит через українську ГТС, за даними
"Укртрансгазу", в минулому році становив понад
80 мільярдів кубометрів, тобто більше,
ніж потенційна потужність нової російської труби.
Утім, українська ГТС потребує термінової модернізації.
За умов збереження транзиту на теперішньому рівні,
Україна могла б модернізувати ГТС за рахунок
інвестиційної складової тарифу.
Це коштувало би, за оцінками експертів
з енергетики, близько шести мільярдів доларів.
Оскільки "Газпром" неодноразово заявляв, що або
мінімізує, або й узагалі припинить газопостачання
через Україну завдяки "Північному потоку-2",
з точки зору Німеччини, вона просто замінить одну трубу
- українську - на іншу - дном Балтійського моря.
До того ж, газопровід будують приватні компанії,
тож сама Німеччина, з економічної точки зору,
нічого не втрачає, радше навпаки - отримає газ
напряму з Росії і за нижчими тарифами.
Водночас для Росії, з економічної точки зору,
"Північний потік-2" – дорога інвестиція.
Адже "Газпром" має вкласти в нього, за оцінками
російських експертів, загалом близько 31 мільярда євро
- тоді як вже існує більш потужна українська ГТС.
З іншого боку, нова труба повністю належатиме "Газпрому",
маршрут транзиту по Росії суттєво скорочується і
не потрібно платити за транзит територією України, Польщі, Білорусі.
Чисто математично, модернізувати українську ГТС
за 6 мільярдів євро за рахунок інвестиційної
складової тарифу на транзит дешевше, ніж
прокладати нову трубу вартістю 9 мільярдів євро
для європейських компаній і понад 30 мільярдів для "Газпрома".
Але є ще багато інших факторів.
Завдяки "Північному потоку-2" Росія отримує власну
нову трубу, стає незалежною від української ГТС,
скорочує маршрут та заощаджує кошти за транзит.
Німеччина отримує газ прямо з Росії і за нижчими тарифами,
по суті, нічого не вкладаючи, адже будують трубу приватні компанії.
Найбільших втрат зазнає Україна - понад
два мільярди євро збитків і поступова втрата ГТС
через скорочення транзиту та грошей на модернізацію.